welcome to my how to read Unicode from
websites such as twitter tutorial turns
out this is actually one of the higher
requested videos and actually every time
it's been requested it's been requested
for Arabic so that's what we're gonna be
using is Arabic although this will
really work for any language it doesn't
have to be Arabic it just is going to be
Arabic in this case and this is going to
be from Twitter now an interesting
little tidbit for you guys the reason
why so many people have requested this
like I've gotten I like I don't know how
many requests but a decent amount of
requests and it's always Arabic and so I
was kind of curious but Twitter usage by
population is the highest in Saudi
Arabia so over 30 percent of Saudi
Arabia's population is on and using
Twitter so so actually it's pretty
imperative that you know how to read the
Arabic Unicode because so many people
look at you know Twitter makes for a
really good data sample or especially
something like there a place like Saudi
Arabia but when you get the output from
Twitter it looks something like like
this right and I actually took an image
of the exact same thing so like here is
although that's in UNIX UNIX timestamp
but this is the actual output right this
is the Unicode here and then the output
that we want is actually this right it's
this of course I probably don't really
want to advertise that website but
anyway this is the Arabic that we want
to output from from that previous
message and actually interestingly
enough Twitter doesn't even get this box
right this is actually a heart as you'll
see you later on when we actually
finally convert this so we'll give you
an even better representation that even
Twitter gives you so probably one of the
reasons why this is so highly requested
that I give a tutorial on this is this
right here it's it's the fact that this
is Unicode and I think
unicode's a lot like regular expressions
probably even more so than regular
expressions people just don't understand
Unicode and it comes up fairly rarely
enough to the point where you can get by
for a really really long time
quite possibly even a whole career
without ever considering what the heck
Unicode even is so eventually it's gonna
be necessary if you continue dealing
with this to actually learn what Unicode
is so in this tutorial I'm not gonna be
teaching you guys exactly what Unicode
is it's just a data type basically but
as far as like how to actually work with
Unicode I'm not gonna do that in this
tutorial this tutorial I'm gonna be
straight-up
tutorial on how to read Unicode from
these kinds of websites and output
exactly what you want so that's what
this tutorial be eventually I'll
probably do one also on just like a
holistic Unicode what the heck is it and
how to work with just Unicode in general
but for now this would just mean how to
read any language basically that's been
converted so I was right you got ASCII
characters but any any language that
uses another symbol besides you know our
typical European alphabet you're gonna
be in trouble so so the first thing you
want to do is let's just see when we
print s to console you could probably
either type this out loud chatting or
I'll just put this in the description so
you can just copy and paste it but let's
see what happens when we print that to
console what happens we'll you'll notice
that it actually prints it to console
and it does a little something a little
funny when you highlight it it's because
Arabic is read right to left so when you
go to highlight usually when one
highlights something one really wants
the first character so as you highlight
it's gonna give you the first second
third character in the real way that you
really wanted it but you just didn't
know it so it's just automatically
flipping for you so that's all that's
happening there just in case someone's
like what the heck anyway so that's that
now you'll see what it free when you
print
out what this is it looks great but then
what happens when we go to like save it
so let's say output file equals open
output text with the intention to pens
and then output dot right we want s and
then output closed and now let's write
that and you'll see that you actually
end up with a pre nasty little error
here because it's trying to write it as
ASCII code and this is not in the range
of 128 right so generally ASCII code
you're gonna have a 0 to a 127 and
that's just gonna be your typical
characters whereas here this is not your
typical character right so because this
is you know Unicode number 627 644 and
so on and just has another tippet
Unicode usually I think it gives us 1.1
million total and we're not even close I
think we've used like 10% of that or
something so just as a quick aside I'll
talk more about that whenever I do in
Unicode tutorial but anyway obviously
these are all exceeding that typical
number so what do we need to do well
this is where you have to use encoding
and decoding now again part of the issue
is that people just don't understand
what's actually happening
we've encode and decode things so let me
show you guys like a way that you would
do something like this right so what
what this is is in theory kind of like
the raw Unicode so now what we want to
do is encode it so like let's say I'll
just call it encoded I suppose and
that's going to equal s dot and code and
then you put in here how you want to
encode that in our case we want to
encode it in utf-8 so then we can print
encode it and for now I'm going to
comment this out so doesn't do anything
and you can see how that looks right
because your console is going to try it
and your console basically had like
these default settings and it's going to
try it's best to give you what you
wanted but a lot of times if you know
what you're doing it's not going to give
you what you wanted but don't worry
about this for now I know that sounds
horrible but just don't worry for now
so now let's uncomment this out and
output and this time all we want to do
is write in end coded so then save that
and then we'll run this and you see how
the out what the output looks like but
then when we actually open up that
output file that will be in the same
directory you'll see that this is
actually what you get you get this and
this is this is what you wanted right as
your output now let me close that it is
now obviously this is what got printed
to your console so if you if you cared
enough to fix that you would you would
print the raw Unicode right to your
console and obviously don't forget well
there's a couple things that happen here
one is this backslash everything has to
be you know a backslash you and you want
to precede it with a u it's like what
would happen if we did this and then
we'll comment this out come at this
happened this happened that out and we
just had s what's gonna print that
writes it's it's gonna treat it just
like a string because that's that that's
the type you're telling hi thon what it
is so you're adding you to it to tell it
hey this is a Unicode string and then
now obviously when you print that to
console you get this so if you wanted to
also print a console you would print s
to console right but then if you wanted
to save that data you would need to
encode it into utf-8 and save that data
now this is just the beginning of the
entire process of how you would maybe
handle this with with Twitter so I'm
gonna go through and do this entire
thing with specifically the Twitter
stream just because like I said every
request has been not only for Arabic but
also with Twitter specifically so this
isn't you know a full completed Twitter
too
so in the next video we're gonna be
digging in a little bit further to
working using this kind of idea with
with Twitter and how to do it so anyway
if this answers your question then no
need to carry on but if you still want
to know how to use it with Twitter then
feel free to carry on as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
the subscription and until next time